Chris you know but my this is my
favorite segment of the week because
I've already put the hay in the barn the
works already done that I my Power
Rankings are compiled this is your
opportunity to throw darts at my work
product and you have been I must say
very charitable maybe it means I've
stepped up my game and I've done a
better job than I have in the past so
you don't have anything to complain
about but yeah it's early here's I
haven't had to complain about too much
or as of late you're right you've been
spot I think you know pretty good pretty
good at these Power Rankings I'm sure
you'll mess them up more as the year
goes along no don't worry
but this year's easier because it really
does feel like there's a cluster of
great teams there's a cluster of crap
teams and then there's the middle yeah
and we're already there three weeks in
where we can discern and Devine where
these teams are so let's get rolling
with the Power Rankings based upon
everything through week three we call
them the week for Power Rankings because
it sounds newer if you use week four
instead of week three and here we go at
number one shocker all season long so
far the New England Patriots three and
oh they have been dominant now their
opponents are a combined zero and none
so they really haven't played anyone yet
but they have dispatched very easily
everyone that they have played Chiefs at
number two Cowboys at three in the Rams
at four unchanged from last week Chris
and let's just stop right there
yeah because to me it feels like those
four yeah are clearly the best teams in
the NFL and then it's everyone else
trying to disrupt that reality no I'm
with you there they are there's the best
four teams in football they got
everything you won their battle tested
they're the cream of the crop right now
let me just ask you this with the top
four did you think about any finagling
there was there any thought of maybe the
the Rams at three or the Cowboys at two
in front of the Chiefs or you feel good
about your top four I don't like to make
a change I don't like to drop a team
that wins unless they win under very
questionable circumstances yeah where
they just had a really bad game and they
got lucky they barely beat a bad team
right I mean the Chiefs handled the
Ravens the Cowboys handled the Dolphins
even though it was closer than 31 to 6
would suggest and and then the Rams did
not have a holic
victory in Cleveland if they had won
that game by 20 or more points then
maybe you bump them up to number three I
don't know but I really don't like
dropping teams when they win because I
don't want to have my email box full of
complaints from from the fans of a team
who won and got dropped so yes I don't
want to be bothered with a bunch of
people complaining how did you drop my
team when my team won its game alright
let's continue with the rest of the top
ten yeah Packers at number five they're
up two spots from number seven getting
that victory over the Denver Broncos and
also some teams in front of them losing
the Baltimore Ravens down are they
actually how do I move them up I guess I
moved them up because all these other
teams lost and they did acquit
themselves well as they would say in
Kansas City so the Ravens actually move
up in playing the Chiefs tougher than
expected and losing to Casey Saints
actually bump up a couple of spots
because they beat the Seattle Seahawks
Vikings up two spots by beating the
Oakland Raiders handily the Seahawks
dropped from five all the way to nine
and the Bears are up from 12 to 10
there's the top ten yeah no big issues I
think you're a little high on the Ravens
like I think I would have had Saints six
Viking seven Seahawks eight Ravens nine
if I had to do my power rankings okay I
think you're given that you know my
thing I'll say is this I mean they were
the the Baltimore Ravens were to miracle
just Hail Mary throws in the air from
being blown out of the gym I mean on a
fourth and five I'm gonna get sacked let
me just throw the ball up in the air
they get it they get a completion there
there was the third and 17 where he
scrambled to the right sideline and
threw it all the way across the field
for a completion you know those were two
miracle plays that kept the game
somewhat interesting but if they don't
happen and I don't think you can depend
on that on a weekly basis that they're
gonna lose far worse than what they did
so I think I would have the Ravens a
little lower so I'm saying defend
yourself Mike Florio no I but but I
still think the Ravens are one of the
best teams in the AFC and I look I
didn't expect them to go into Kansas
City and win and autom Utley they dug
out of a hole they did have some luck
they did do some things that were
questionable from a decision-making
standpoint going forward
or town going for two I understand John
Harbaugh is explanation I still don't
believe that you always go simply by the
analytics I think you have to understand
as we said yesterday if you're if you're
two-point conversion plays aren't
working right at a certain point you
should stop doing them Yeah right even
though the Board says you should do them
or your high-level analytics when you're
down by eleven you go ahead and go for
two so then you get score ten and you're
winning regulation I get all that I just
don't get continuing to do something
that hasn't been working and for the
Ravens going for two was not working
I you know I let's let's add but I don't
disagree with you you know I I look at
the I'm trying to figure out who would
be number six yes stead of them though I
guess right if the Ravens aren't six do
you move the Saints all the way to
number six it was kind of a fluke II win
Seahawks day well the Vikings don't
deserve to be number six although you
can argue maybe they are number six they
barely lost to the Packers in the
Packers at number five that's right so
maybe the Vikings and maybe the Vikings
should have gone from 10 all the way to
number six but regardless it after you
get through the past four it does get a
little more jumbled because there are
some some good teams that are hovering
there and yes the what those teams are
gonna be yeah they let's look at the
rest of the yeah please the rest of the
team please into the end of the second
ten the cults at number 11 a team that
we need to take very seriously because
they look better and better all the time
yes they thought Andrew Luck the bills
at number 12 they are undefeated there
are Bills fans who think they should be
higher 49ers at 13 I get the same
argument they're undefeated they should
be higher than that I still want to see
more from these teams before they crack
the top ten Texans moved up six with
that win at La over the Chargers they
are at 14 they were at number 20
chargers at number 15 jaguars at number
16 after beating the Tennessee Titans
Titans at 17 Browns at 18 they dropped
three spots after losing to the Rams
Lions at 19 even though they're
technically undefeated and I dropped the
Eagles Chris yeah you know I feel bad
about this they're my NFC Super Bowl
pick yeah I dropped him from 6 all the
way to number 20 yeah I think that's
that's ok right now I mean they're 1 & 2
they lost a home football game to the
Lions they're finding ways to screw
games up and the other
100% health-wise but you're ranking the
teams as they are right now you're not
ranking them to what they're gonna be
when they are healthy so I got no issue
with that I mean we talked about it
offense they're turning the ball over
they're dropping passes defense can't
rush the passer there's issues in
Philadelphia I'm not mad at you where I
am mad at ya okay is I do think I think
you're I think I would have the bills in
the 49ers over the Bears who you have at
number 10 right now I might have the
bills in the 49ers over the nine
Seahawks right now the nine and ten
Seahawks and bears that's where I had
pushed back on your you know 11 through
22 a little bit I do think you're
disrespecting the 49ers more than the
bills I understand the trepidation about
the bills but I think the 49ers I
wouldn't put them up in front of the
Seahawks and the Bears right now for the
way they've looked the first three three
games but they both went up four spots
see the problem is when you start you
know it's a gradual climb and as you
keep winning you keep climbing so it's
incumbent on the 49ers and on the bills
to keep winning and the bills get their
opportunity this weekend in the annual
visit by Tom Brady to Buffalo New Era
feels that game what is involved what's
the game called
I don't know what the game so the game
is called the unidentified flying object
game although we know what the object
that's flying through the air we say
that were not air can't we say don't
want to find out I was on KJR in Seattle
last night and they said the word and I
could tell that the host was very
concerned right after he said the word
then maybe he shouldn't have said the
word and all I said was you said it not
me buddy yep that's all right oh yeah
it's the adult toy game let's say that
okay it's always excited I will be tuned
in just for that I promise you I will be
watching to see when the adult toy flies
on to the field in our annual tradition
up in Buffalo I hope somebody through
this no I don't we do not encourage it
we do not condone it it is a safety
hazard the first year they did it it was
actually on the field somebody got a
stamp on it yeah so do not do it bill
we're not saying that like hey go ahead
and do it do not do it I'm saying
do it but just make sure nobody's around
and don't hurt any players or anybody
like that but do it please do it how do
you how do you screen to make sure when
somebody's entering the stadium you know
it's like this is this real sir we don't
let these objects in the stadia are you
planning on using this during the game
no I'm not I just wanted it I just
wanted it in my bag I just I mean this
is a real concern if your bill security
this is if you're having your meeting
with all the security guards and you're
like what are our topics for the week
what's our big concern our big concern
is ferreting out these items that may
end up being thrown through the air and
land on the field and hit somebody or
create some sort of a hazard yeah all
right bottom of the rankings the
Dolphins oh and three they'd be lower
than 32 if we could put them there the
the Washington franchise has fallen to
31 the Jets are 30 the Giants moved up
from 29 to 24 our 31 to 25 by beating
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers but Dad you
know the worst teams are settling in
what we know that that's where they're
gonna be all year long I don't see that
changing very much Chris no I can't see
it changing a whole lot either I mean I
mean I guess I think the Jets are worse
than the Redskins at this point I might
have put them a little lower but the
rest of your the rest of your group
there as far as 23 through 32 I don't
have any pushback the one thing I will
say out of that group there where I look
at them and I go those the majority of
those teams it's done it's over I still
give the Panthers a little bit of a
fighting chance to find their way out
and maybe still be in a spot when cam
Knuth and Cam Newton does get healthy to
where they might still be able to make a
run at the playoffs or do something then
one team might look at the bottom of
your rankings where I go there's still a
gleam there's still a glimmer that they
could pull this together and be somewhat
relevant if Cam Newton gets healthy I
think Kyle Allen is gonna be able to
continue this all year long no I know
I've gotta get back to the guy that
we're accustomed to seeing and that's
what's so weird when we see him play
yeah and it's
he's not the guy at least we now know
that it was that foot injury because
after that week two loss on Thursday
night to the Tampa Bay Buccaneers and
everyone's insisting Cam's fine Cam's
fine Cam's fine it's like well if he's
fine then he stinks Yeah right if he's
not injured he'd better be injured it
could be as bad as he was as inaccurate
as he was and now we know his his foot
was messed up and it was harder for him
to plant and throw the football
you